I have amazing news I think that when I
die the thing that I will be most proud
of is not the businesses that I've built
but the books that I've written Alex for
Mosey 100 million dollar offers sold
over 430 000 copies I launched it before
I had an audience
I have been working for two years on a
single project that Launches on August
19th great writing comes from a place of
wanting to add to the body of knowledge
100 literal leads is finally here we're
launching it on August 19th at a live
event I'm gonna make this the Super Bowl
for entrepreneurship I put a million
bucks into the event to make it
unbelievable for you guys and hopefully
just a spoiled imagination and go over
the top with the amount of things we've
been giving away but it's only going to
be for people who are live there with me
so you're not going to miss it go to the
link acquisition.com forward slash leads
and I will see you guys there invite
your friends